we should be focusing laser like on
China we should not be focusing on the
war in Ukraine and the war in the Middle
East but it was through our foolish
policies in the past uh that we failed
to prevent these two Wars from breaking
out and got ourselves deeply involved in
both of them to the detriment of
American foreign
[Music]
policy welcome to this II opening
interview um I'm Alexis papazoglu I'm a
senior editor for the online magazine of
The Institute of Art and ideas and I'm
delighted to have as our guest today
John mimer he is the r Wendell Harrison
distinguished service professor of
political science at the University of
Chicago and is considered to be one of
the most influential international
relations theorists of his generation he
is the author among other books of how
States think the rationality of foreign
policy and the great delusion liberal
dreams and international
realities so without further Ado John
Mir shimer Welcome to The Institute of
Art and ideas thank you glad to be here
so you are one of the key proponents of
what is known as the realist School of
international relations which is this
kind of framework that tries to explain
the behavior of States as rational
actors aiming to maximize things like
power and security can you tell us just
brief why is this the best framework for
explaining how States behave in your
view well it's very simple it's the best
explanation because that is how the
world
Works uh but also because there is a
compelling logic that
underpins uh the realist story and it
goes like this we live in a world where
there is no higher authority that can
protect States if they get into trouble
and at the same time we live in a world
where it's very difficult to tell what
the intentions of other states are today
and certainly what they will be in the
future so there may be some powerful
State out there that has malign
intentions towards your state and if it
comes after you there is no higher
authority to protect you and in a world
like that it makes eminently good sense
to be really powerful because if you're
really powerful it's highly unlikely
that another state will attack you all
states of course understand this basic
logic and the end result is that all
states compete for power among
themselves so you get security
competition among the great Powers all
the time and of course sometimes that
security competition leads to war So
speaking of War you have very famously
argued that this realist this realist
framework explains essentially why
Russia
was going to attack Ukraine and why it
has attacked Ukraine and the idea is
that it was trying to prevent it from
becoming a security risk uh given its
Ambitions and plans to join NATO and
NATO's open door
policy um a criticism of of this
position of this explanation have
pointed out that this realist framework
doesn't quite explain why Russia had to
invade Ukraine by land rather than
simply say Bomb It by air and to them
this looks more like uh an attempt to
conquer Ukraine an attempt to absorb it
into Russia not merely to neutralize it
or um uh prevent it from becoming a
security threat so how do you how do you
understand that
criticism well there's no question that
uh the conventional wisdom in the west
uh has long been that Putin was an
imperialist he was bent on creating a
greater Russia and that's the reason he
invaded in February
2022 my argument is that there's no no
evidence to support this uh and there is
an abundance of evidence to make the
case that Putin feared Ukraine becoming
a Western bwar on Russia's border and
most importantly he feared Ukraine
becoming a member of NATO and he and the
other Russian Elites uh were dedicated
to making sure that didn't happen and
they couldn't do it diplomatically they
tried they tried to reach a deal with
the United States stes to get the United
States in the west to call off NATO
expansion into Ukraine but they failed
and he felt that he had no
alternative uh but to invade uh Ukraine
uh I think using air power is your
question referred to would have made no
sense at all he was not going to get
much leverage from bombing Ukraine and
it made much more sense to launch a
limited Invasion which is what he did
but you still don't think the the aim of
Russia was to essentially uh or is at
the moment to conquer Ukraine to trying
to absorb it into Russia's
orbit no I think that since the war has
started uh there's no question that
Russia's territorial Ambitions have
escalated and they have already annexed
four oblas in Ukraine and I would expect
them to Annex a few more oblas I don't
think they're going to try to conquer
all of Ukraine I think Ukraine uh will
remain as sovereign state but there's no
question that it'll be a dysfunctional
State and that's Putin's goal to turn
Ukraine into a dysfunctional State a
dysfunctional rum State as I like to say
so that it's no threat to Russia I mean
another criticism of this approach and
one that tries to point to some evidence
that maybe Putin was interested in in
conquering uh Ukraine is this famous
essay that Vladimir Putin published in
July of 2021 uh called on the historical
Unity of Russians and ukrainians and
some analysts have seen this sort of
underlying motivation for why Putin
invaded Ukraine uh and a telling sign
that this was indeed intended as a war
of Conquest not just a sort of Hit and
Run job as it were so why does um why do
you think the realist framework sort of
underplays dramatic Declarations of
ideology by political leaders like this
when when trying trying to explain their
behavior and how they act
I think that July 12 2021 article that
Putin wrote uh says exactly the opposite
of what you said uh it represents uh it
doesn't make an argument in there that
Putin sees Ukraine as part of Russia and
that he is bent on conquering Ukraine in
fact if you read that piece carefully it
makes it clear that Putin wck recognizes
Ukrainian nationalism he recognizes the
settlement of December 1991 when the
Soviet Union fell apart uh and that he
believes Ukraine's future is up to
Ukraine uh what he also makes clear uh
in that essay and in all sorts of other
places is that Ukraine cannot become
part of NATO because that is an
existential threat to Russia and that's
the basic story I tell but I don't know
why proponents of the argument that
Putin was an imperialist and was bent on
conquering Ukraine point to that July 12
2021 essay because it says the exact
opposite of what they claim it says okay
that's an interesting disagreement I
guess but what about the wider Point
putting this particular essay aside that
the realist framework is too focused on
sort of structural issues and ignores
potentially ideological reasons that
might be mo motivating the actions of
world leaders State leaders and so on so
looking more at a kind of objective
picture and less at kind of the ideas
that might be behind um the actions of
people like
Putin well I think there's no question
that ideology matters somewhat uh in the
decision making of almost all leaders
the question is how much does it matter
and my argument is that in the vast
majority of cases ideology does not
matter much at all that what really
matters are balance of power
considerations states are primarily
concerned about their survival and if
you're primarily concerned about your
survival then you worry about the
balance of power more than anything else
and if you look at Putin's thinking
before uh the war in Ukraine it's very
clear that he was thinking about Ukraine
as an existential threat Ukraine in NATO
as an exist po ential threat and he was
interested in preventing that from
happening this was not a case of
ideology at play and in fact Putin
doesn't have much of an ideology this is
not the Soviet Union with a communist
ideology and despite the fact that lots
of people like to portray Putin uh as
the second coming of Adolf Hitler this
is not a case of fascism or Nazism at
play it's good oldfashioned balance of
power politics and people in the west
should have had the good sense to
understand that expanding NATO into
Ukraine was going to lead to the
destruction of Ukraine and that is
exactly what's happening now to mention
another famous work that you you are
known for which is the Israel Lobby and
the US foreign policy in which you
document this kind of remarkable level
of support both material and diplomatic
by the United States to the state of
Israel something that of course we're
witnessing again today
and you have argued that this support
cannot be fully explained on on merely
strategic grounds and it has more to do
with the political influence of um you
know certain individuals and
organizations that act uh to shape US
foreign policy in a in a pro-israel
Direction so is this not a kind of
falsification of your own realist thesis
in the sense that this is proof that
states don't always behave merely in
accordance with their power and security
interests but they can be uh influenced
by IDE ologies or particular people that
capture
power yes there's no question about it
this is a case that uh violates my basic
realist theory of international politics
and indeed Steve Walt who is my
co-author on that book uh is a realist
as well and has he has a different
realist theory of international politics
than I do but Steve would readily admit
that the case uh violates his theory as
well it's very important to understand
that theories are simplifications of
reality the fact is we live in an
enormously complicated world and to make
sense of that world we need simple
theories but because there's
simplifications of a complex reality
those theories are sometimes going to be
wrong and I argue this is an intuition
on my part that the best theories in
international politics get it right
about 75% of the time which means that
you're wrong 25% of the time and I think
the case the Israel Lobby where domestic
politics overwhelm strategic
considerations is a case that
contradicts my theory interesting that
yeah you don't think that counter
example is a sort of definitive um
falsification of of the theory um do you
make any adjustments based on based on
that uh paper and and then book that you
wrote do you think that the realist
framework should adjust in some ways to
make to make sense of these counter
examples and allow for a greater role of
ideologies and ideas and influence by
other means that have less to do with
security and power to to play a
role no because then it wouldn't be a
realist Theory and furthermore it
wouldn't be simple a simple explanation
of how the world Works which is what a
theory is uh you're just complexifying
the theory and once you complexify a
theory by adding more and more factors
uh into the story it Seas to be a
meaningful Theory I think you just have
to accept the fact which many people
find it hard to do that theories don't
always work that sometimes they're
falsified and this is a case so to move
on to um a little bit about what's
happening in the Middle East as well
you're you're a big proponent of the
so-called us pivot to China and this is
a policy that was adopted already by the
Obama
Administration and you're critical of
the United States for sort of getting
bogged down in Russia
now getting involved again in the Middle
East rather than focusing on its main
adversary who you see in I think the
United States sees as being
China there are those who argue sort of
the opposite that the outbreak of these
two conflicts are in fact the
consequence of the US dropping the ball
as it were in the Middle East and
Eastern Europe and that focusing only on
China is a thing that have led the world
going up in Flames as we see it so what
do you what do you make of that is it
credible critique of US foreign policy
as we're seeing it well first of all as
I've tried to make clear I believe the
United States is principally responsible
for the Ukraine War uh I believe the
United States was the principal driving
force behind NATO expansion and that's
what led to this War uh and with regard
to the Middle East I think if the United
States had put significant pressure on
Israel uh which it was trying to do
since at least the Carter Administration
to uh achieve a two-state solution uh
where you had a Palestinian State living
next door to a Jewish State you would
not have the conflict between Hamas and
Israel today so I think the United
States failed on that front as well
although there I think it was mainly
because of the Israel Lobby I think that
American policy makers uh going back to
Carter and moving forward understood the
importance of a two-state solution but
they just couldn't get it uh and they
couldn't get it because of pressure from
the lobby but anyway the end result of
all this is that we're bogged down uh in
Ukraine we're bogged down now in the
Middle East there's no hope of us
getting out of either one of those
conflicts anytime soon and this is
preventing us from fully pivoting to
Asia to deal with a threat that really
matters there's no question that China
is the principal threat to the United
States today it is a peer competitor and
we should be focusing laser like on
China we should not be focusing on uh
the war in Ukraine and the war in the
Middle East but it was through our
foolish policies in the past uh that we
failed to prevent these two Wars from
breaking out and got ourselves deeply
involved in both of them to the
detriment of American foreign
policy so you mentioned the two-state
solution there about um sort of Israel
Palestine why do you think this solution
hasn't happened given that as you as you
see it in some others see it it would be
the best guarantor of the security of
Israel and so again if we follow the
realist framework a rational State
should be pursuing it and instead Israel
has been sabotaging it for you know
decades so why do you think this is how
do you end up explaining it through
again your kind of ir framework well I
think in the case of uh the two-state
solution uh there are certainly some
Palestinians who were not interested in
that uh outcome for sure and to begin
with Arafat yaser Arafat was in that
category but he eventually uh changed
his thinking on the matter and became
committed to a two-state solution and
mmud abas who is his successor uh and
now basically runs the Palestinian
Authority in the West Bank is committed
to a two-state solution so there are
Palestinians and there have been a long
for a long time Palestinian leaders who
are committed to the two-state solution
it's been very difficult to get the
Israelis to agree to a two-state
solution I think there was only one time
where that happened and that was with
ahood Barack uh and that surrounded the
very famous Camp David meeting in 2000
but I think even there in that one case
the Israelis were not willing to go to
all not willing to go all the way and
give the Palestinian Ians a meaningful
state of their own and since 2000 uh
there has been little interest in a
two-state solution in Israel and the
government now has uh a great interest
if anything in trying to prevent a
two-state solution so even if the United
States pushes hard uh it's going to run
into a tremendous amount of resistance
but the United States can't push hard
because of the lobby
so do you see this resistance on the
part of Israel as as rational like would
it would it be perhaps more of a
security threat if it did have another
state on its borders potentially hostile
with more infrastructure and so on
potentially a military than the
situation we have now
or and if and if that isn't the case
what's preventing it at the moment from
from seeing that as a possible solution
is it is it ideology again getting in
the
way well I think you know in the past
you could make the case it was largely
ideology that Israelis wanted a greater
Israel they wanted an Israel that
included the West Bank and Gaza uh I
think now uh the real problem is the
security problem that you describe it's
hard to imagine given the war that's
taking place and given what happened on
October 7th that the Israelis would be
willing to countenance creating a
Palestinian state on their border Israel
after all is a very small country and uh
putting a Palestinian state right on its
border uh when that Palestinian State
might have aggressive intentions uh is
really not in the card so I I think we
have a situation here where the
possibility of a two-state solution
which I think was very real in the past
is no longer a realistic outcome I just
wanted to ask you about um what I see
sometimes as a tension in your approach
um so sometimes you you use the realist
framework to sort of describe what is
going on the ground why states are
behaving in certain ways and then other
times like when you criticize the United
States for you know not directing its
full attention to China and instead
having its involvement with Russia and
now in the Middle East you seem to use
the the realist framework not as a tool
to explain what's going on but as a tool
about for saying as a guide for saying
what should be happening so as a
normative tool um to to say the US
should be doing this should be doing
that it should be pursuing its security
interest in this way so how do you
negotiate this kind of tension is is the
realist framework good for describing
things or is it good for prescribing how
States should behave that's a great
question the answer is it's good for
both as I said before uh no Theory gets
it right all of the time and that means
that states sometimes do not act
according to basic realist logic or at
least according to John's realist logic
and I of course think that's a mistake
that it would make good sense for states
to always operate according to realist
logic uh but the fact that they don't
always do that remember I said before I
thought that and this is an intuition on
my part that roughly 20 5% of the time
states don't act uh according to realist
logic I think therefore it makes sense
uh to uh argue that states should do
this or should do that if they're not
acting according to realist logic so it
is both an explanatory Theory and a
normative Theory someone might say that
that's a bit like cheating though
because on the one hand you know if as a
social scientist you're trying to
describe reality
and then you have a theory you put it
forward and sometimes it doesn't behave
reality doesn't behave like you predict
then you just turn around and say well
that's reality's fault reality should be
behaving according to my theory what do
you say to that I no I think that's just
the way the world works I mean that
that's the way social science Works
you're saying that somebody should come
up with a theory that explains every
case you're saying in effect that a
theory uh should be a perfect
explanation of how the world works
there's no social thought science theory
whether you're talking about economics
or political science or sociology that's
going to fit that description remember
the world is an incredibly complicated
place and theories are simplifications
of reality you leave out certain factors
when you craft a theory and sometimes
those factors that you leave out really
matter and your theory in those cases is
FAL fals ifed but that's just the way
social science works there's no way that
anyone can come up with a theory that
explains every case before you were
talking about adding more factors like
domestic politics and ideology and so
forth and so on to my theory but as I
said then as I'll say again you no
longer have a theory once you do that
because theories are simple descriptions
of reality and when they become
complicated explanations they don't
become explanations they're just
descriptions well John Mir shimer thank
you very
[Music]
much